[Music]
you have not been home in days barely
sleep when you are home how many times a
night you like that fist up
I see how much you're pushing yourself
just trying to keep the peace what am I
supposed to do I didn't ask the iron
twist I'm fighting for what I believe in
no matter the cost
what are you fighting for
trying to do what's right I didn't
expect to see you here brother we have
family matters to discuss you in Davos
we were training together
[Applause]
I fought my brother there is no changing
what happened do you feel that you can
just walk through this world as if it
belongs to the iron fist
such a weapon to be held it is to
release
[Music]
now you'll give me also mine brother
you will suffer
the iron fist that was one today
we can stop them but I need help you're
not alone
but you can't save everyone
I can't just sit here and do nothing
I have become the same
you never had the strength to be
reasons aside what happens next
why do
we should do this process in or out a
movie
[Music]
day night
[Music]